after two days of violence baghdad's
heavily fortified green zone is emptying
of protesters
a sharp contrast to earlier scenes
violence broke out on monday when
powerful shiite leader moqtada al-sada
announced he would quit politics
[Applause]
a day later he apologized and called on
his supporters to stand down and go home
there are some brutal militias but the
satirist shouldn't be vulgar i still
believe that my supporters are
disciplined that's why if you don't
withdraw from the parliament within 60
minutes i am not going to be the
soldering movement leader again i don't
even want you to stage a peaceful
demonstration
[Applause]
it's not the first time sudden
supporters have forced their way into
the presidential compound they've been
demonstrating for months
this is a political rivalry between
two
different parties or sides of the
spectrum one side
trying to maintain the consensus
agreement of the consultational
democracy impulse 2003 iraq and the
other side which is the soldiers
movement trying to
revamp the political system in iraq
his party won the most parliament seats
in elections in october but failed to
form a majority coalition
sardo may have told his supporters to
stand down but with such intense rivalry
at the heart of iraqi politics there are
fears it's only a matter of time before
chaos and bloodshed is repeated
laura about a manly al jazeera